leah thomas  never  says anything about  his teammates  i'm happy this makes me feel good  that's all he ever says because the the  the women the actual women involved  don't factor in they don't matter he  doesn't care he's a raging narcissist we  actually spoke to one of the teammates  of leah thomas there was a lot of things  you couldn't talk about that were very  concerning like a locker room situation  if you even brought up concerns about it  you were transphobic they said look we  understand there's an array of emotions  but leah's swimming is a non-negotiable  however we can help you make that okay  that's what we're here for what you just  heard there that's gaslighting  where  if you have a problem  if you're uncomfortable  being around a man in your locker room  if you don't want to see a penis in a  locker room then you are the one with  the problem